mit maske und negativem corona
testbesuchen wir familie will bads in
trier
vater mutter und sieben kinder wohnen
hier montagmorgen sieht nur 30
eigentlich wären fünf kinder längst in
der schule oder kita
doch momentan geht es bei der familie
wilbers morgens noch lauter zu als vor
corona
[Musik]
ein dankeschön geht an den ganzen tag so
bald david moss und 6 uhr soll das und
geht dann eigentlich
seitdem ist ab und zu dürfen zumindest
die kleinen jungs in die kita immerhin
wird denn für dich corona warum ist mir
fast jeden tag langweilig weil ich die
hälfte von meinen spielen schlafen in
die durchgespielt haben und dann teil
von mir freundin einmal würde es bei
einer woche und ich mache mir auch
sorgen wenn meine oma meine mutter bei
der risikopatienten sind und dadurch
kann ich auch mal kurz in meinem kurs
englisch sehen wenn sieben kinder
zwischen zwei und 17 jahren was den
ganzen tag zuhause festhängen ist das
anstrengend für alle
wann immer er kann unterstützt vaters
wenn seine frau nadine der haushalt
kommt trotzdem zu kurz und das busfahrer
gehalt reicht auch nicht aus weil auch
die kostenlosen schul und kita essen
wegfallen
und natürlich jetzt wo die kinder zu
hause sind haut extrem das loch in die
haushaltskasse
wir müssen da jetzt mit klarkommen an
allen ecken gespart von mir das nicht
wie lange das ganze dauert und der block
down wo die kinder dann noch zu hause
sind und kinder dürfen nie irgendwie zu
kurz kommen dann sparen wir eben an den
eltern und an der auswahl ob es gesund
ernährung oder weniger gesunde ernährung
muss halt auf den preis achten
mehr aus also monat geben also prima dem
rudel drei bis 500 euro mehr aus wir
essen ohne irgendwelchen luxus sondern
ein nur fürs essen
der kinderzuschlag der zusätzlich kamen
das war ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
so weil kinder kosten geld und leben
nicht von luft und liebe alleine denn
sind kinder er iris herrmann haushalten
die sind bleiben auf der strecke und
werden an gelassen
seit monaten geht das nun schon wieder
so die geschwister sind liebevoll
miteinander
die großen selbst an geduldig wenn sie
beim lernen gestört werden
[Musik]
und wie ist das für dich so so das
auszuhalten kann manchmal nervig sein
weil sie den ganzen tag machen aber dann
ist auch nachmittags euro da gehen sie
meistens halten sie gucken oder gehen
stehen
und mittendrin ist dann noch das
homeschooling die größte herausforderung
für die familie von der zweitklässlerin
bis zum berufsschüler ist alles dabei du
sollst du zu ordnen
na ja dann mache es auch bitte anschluss
zu halten an die schule also den
anschluss hand über nicht weil momentan
ist es gerade der justice und musik
anhören der frauen musik wenn er seine
aufgaben macht sie kommt mit der musik
aber nicht kleine sind sie jetzt hier
unten oder weniger von vier beamten
die nimmt einen halt als lehrer nicht
voll
ich bin halt die mutter ja selbst
schnappte 400 ist jetzt zwar noch ein
kleiner hinten dran weil wir halt jetzt
liegen wir mussten bei der lena jetzt
erstmal musste gucken weil alles in
einer app aber so unübersichtlich dass
die lehrer gar die den geo wirklich
komplett verloren dass alle sieben
kinder trotz corona den anschluss in der
schule behalten fast unmöglich
dabei hat in dem reihenhaus jedes kind
einen kleinen rückzugsort und ab und zu
dürfen die kinder mit dem großen bruder
justin zum naheliegenden reiterhof wo
die oma die reitbeteiligung führpferd
luna zahlt vier und zwei stunden zu
hause bleiben und rausgehen
ich werde zuhause nur noch im bett
schule schlafen
ich wäre eigentlich komplett 24 stunden
zu hause und nur selten raus gehen bei
anderen kindern ist genau das realität
berlin hellersdorf marzahn tag für tag
ist bernd siggelkow hier unterwegs er
hat vor 25 jahren das kinderprojekt die
arche gegründet und kümmert sich um die
kinder die sowieso schon am rand der
gesellschaft stehen und die korona nun
in ganz prekäre situationen bringt ich
bringe jetzt lebensmittel in eine
familie wir haben viele familien die
auch finanziell bedürftig sind weil die
belastung natürlich groß in die kinder
ist nicht mehr in der schule nicht mehr
nach hause
und deswegen brauchen sie oft
unterstützung
jeden tag bringt er essen zu den
abgeschotteten familien so ist er einer
der wenigen der noch kontakt zu den
kindern hält
guck mal seit der show wieder nah er war
schneller als ich dinge kann übernahme
geschätzt hat sie auch an und wie geht
es euch langeweile familie springer hat
große angst sich anzustecken die kinder
dürfen seit monaten nicht mehr in die
arche kommen das gespräch mit bernd
siggelkow an der tür
das highlight der woche mit was du das
mal dass gerade vor gesagt hat aber es
ist komisch wenn man weiß eigentlich
ganz
man weiß gar nicht genau was für ein tag
ist und warum man eine struktur ohne
bedeutet für viele kinder leben im
durchhalte modus und große sorgen
und wie geht es dir im lock down und gut
in einer sache meistens entweder total
überfordert und sitzt in einer ecke und
einem
1 x ich mach das einfach zu viel ist
also die ganze sache so mit corona hause
zusammenbrechen teilen möchte einfach in
sich zusammen rund um das grundwasser
hat jetzt schnell wieder anzukommen
deine probleme war intern lieber mal
statt und wird von den kenne ich von ihr
gar nicht so eigentlich nicht
danke für ein jahr
[Musik]
viele sorgen auf wenig quadratmetern und
kinder die dieser situation schon seit
monaten ausgeliefert sind
[Musik]
das was hinter verschlossenen türen
passiert ist ein akt des grauens das man
nicht beschreiben kann weil die meisten
sind wenn ich das hilfesystem ist
runtergefahren die meisten
jugendeinrichtungen sind gar nicht da
wir sehen viele dinge an der tür oder
wie vermuten sie zumindest wir gehen ja
auch nicht rein dürfen wir auch nicht
aber wir merken schon auch an dem
verhalten von kindern und auch von
eltern wie angespannt die situation ist
und welche problemlagen stauen sich
sander also die hilferufe die uns
erreichen sind in der regel geforderte
menschen menschen nicht mehr
weiterkönnen die von dem system sich
vergessen fühlen die sagen ihr seid die
einzigen die noch für uns da sind wir
können euch per whatsapp telefonisch
erreichen sonst niemanden wir laufen
schon im kopf gegen die wand weil wir
einfach nicht mehr können wir wollen
unsere kinder nicht schlagen und die
kinder wollen auch nicht sich
untereinander schlange
ich glaube dass wir das große problem in
unserer gesellschaft haben dass kinder
nicht in der mitte der gesellschaft
stehen sondern am rand sie sind haben
keine wählerstimme und dann fallen
besonders die durch sie die sowieso es
schwierig haben und dadurch sind die
kinder in großer gefahr
kinder aus benachteiligten familien
verlieren jetzt erst recht den anschluss
studien zeigen aber dass kinder aus
allen sozialen schichten teilweise stark
unter corona leiden
acht von zehn kindern fühlen sich laut
einer untersuchung durch die pandemie
belastet sieben von zehn spüren
geminderte lebensqualität drei von zehn
leiden unter psychischen auffälligkeiten
auch psychosomatische beschwerden traten
bereits im ersten shut down vermehrt auf
neben gereiztheit 54% und
einschlafproblemen 44 prozent sind das
beispielsweise kopf und bauchschmerzen
40 bzw 31 prozent und laut einer
weiteren studie litten bereits im ersten
shut down 9 prozent der kinder unter
zehn jahren gewalt das ist sechs mal
mehr als vor der krise
[Musik]
was konkret fühlen kinder in der krise
wir starten einen aufruf lassen uns
videos schicken von kindern aus dem
ganzen land
eine schule darf ich nicht ich dass du
nicht mein geburtstag feiern
ich durfte mich zu meinen freunden gehen
ja so was ist eigentlich auch langweilig
einfach eine chance durch gunnar bin ich
sehr kreativ geworden
ich bastel und bau gerne sachen mehrheit
verhindert dass ich die manche teams
oder kinder halt ein bisschen mehr
schalten ich bin ich ein schwimmbad
ich bin ich auch dass meine freundin
anni läuft gut in der korona zeit dass
ich meine familie mehr sehr mitgenommen
das allein ist das nicht mehr so viele
hausaufgaben konnte man nicht versteht
man fühlt sich nur gelangweilte dann zu
hause hat die wunde die nerven die
situation von tausenden kindern
wissenschaftlich ausgewertet hat dr
severine thomas von der uni hildesheim
in ihren studien kiko und yuko forschte
sie zu den erfahrungen von kindern und
jugendlichen während der korona pandemie
was ist denn im moment besonders schwer
für kinder und jugendliche ihre kinder
hätten durchaus das würden wir eben auch
jetzt nach fast einem jahr der pandemie
verhaltensauffälligkeiten zeigen
vielleicht aggressionen die man nicht
einordnen kann
oder sind antriebs und das sind auch
auswirkungen des eingeschränkten
sozialen lebens bei jugendlichen besteht
zum reinen tatsächlich hohe sorge und
auch eine starke zukunftsangst die frage
machst du dir sorgen um deine zukunft
und das haben etwa 68 prozent der jungen
menschen bejagt gesagt ja ich mache mir
sorgen um meine zukunft werden kinder
und jugendliche zu wenig gehört wenn man
unsere studienergebnisse nimmt würde ich
sagen auf jeden fall werden sie zu wenig
gehört also wir haben das eben auch
explizit gefragt und da deutlich
formuliert ich habe nicht das gefühl
dass politiker in mein interesse
vertreten es sind nicht nur psychische
veränderungen die sich bei kindern
bemerkbar machen sondern auch
körperliche seit ich den ganzen tag vorm
computer sitze werde ich oft seinem
video und bekommt kopf
ich finde es sehr traurig dass die
jugendlichen fast gar keine
sportmöglichkeiten mehr haben da ich
dass ich jetzt kein training mehr hab ja
ich mach ziemlich wenig sport ich habe
mein essverhalten geändert dass ich es
eigentlich ziemlich viel ungesundes der
leiter der kinderklinik in köln
professor jörg butt hat täglich mit den
körperlichen auswirkungen des shutdown
zu tun
kinder wurden in der krise in meinen
augen zu lange als teil und vielleicht
auch als drei bei der pandemie angesehen
ich glaube es ist viel wichtiger sich
die kinder hineinzuversetzen zu
verstehen was bewegt ein kind und das
kind nicht gleichzusetzen in seinen
möglichkeiten sich auszudrücken einem
erwachsenen menschen
wir wissen wie stark die betroffenen
verbände aller möglichen
wirtschaftsbereiche sich durch ihre
lobbyisten melden und permanent sich
gehör verschaffen das gelingt den
kindern nicht es kann ihnen auch nicht
gelingen und deswegen ist es die aufgabe
der politik sehr viel weniger auf die
lobbyisten verbände zu hören und sehr
viel mehr darauf zu achten was könnten
denn bereiche unserer gesellschaft sein
die besonders verletzlich sind
fassen wir zusammen es gibt viel stress
in den familien kinder leiden sowohl
psychisch als auch körperlich unter den
corona maßnahmen dennoch gelten für
kinder die gleichen regeln wie für
erwachsene
die politik diskutiert richtig und
selbstverständlich über
geschäftseröffnungen und finanz helfen
aber warum hat sie keine kindgerechten
konzepte entwickelt wir finden heraus
organisationen von kindern und
jugendlichen wurden anders als zum
beispiel lobbygruppen in wirtschaft und
profisport kaum angehört oder an corona
entscheidungen beteiligt obwohl
deutschland über die un
kinderrechtskonvention dazu verpflichtet
wäre
wie schlecht in deutschland die
perspektiven von kindern in der pandemie
vertreten wurden weiß claudia dittel die
seit jahren für die un die einhaltung
der kinderrechte in deutschland
überwacht in bezug auf kinderrechte in
der korona krise haben wir vermisst das
nicht von anfang an kinder und
jugendliche angehört wurden bei allen
maßnahmen die getroffen wurden gab es
entscheidungsgremien in denen es noch
nicht man in treffens vertretung von
kindern und jugendlichen gab es wäre ja
schon schön gewesen die bundesministerin
für familie senioren frauen und jugend
wäre dabei gewesen aber die gehörte
anfangs auch nicht zum krisenstab die
entscheidungen sind ganz klassisch über
den kopf von kindern und jugendlichen
hinweg entschieden worden und das ist so
was typisch erwachsene dass man
irgendwie annimmt dass man schon weiß
was für kinder das beste ist aber
deutschland hat die un
kinderrechtskonvention ratifiziert und
dementsprechend müssten in deutschland
bei allen staatlichen maßnahmen müssten
kinder und jugendliche immer gehört
werden
deutschland hat die un
kinderrechtskonvention unterschrieben
und garantiert damit dass kinder in
allen fragen die sie betreffen gehört
werden müssen
doch selbst organisationen wie die
bundesschülerkonferenz oder der
bundesjugendring wurden kaum an
entscheidungen beteiligt so die expertin
und das obwohl auch das leben der kinder
beschnitten wurde
es sind angebote für kinder und
jugendliche weggebrochen und nicht als
systemrelevant eingestuft worden von
denen wir nicht wissen dass sie extrem
wichtig sind kinder wenden sich
beispielsweise an die erzieherin in der
kita an die klassenlehrerin an eine
vertrauensperson im sportverein oder
einer jugendgruppe in der sie irgendwie
aktiv sind wir wissen dass das die
zugänge sind mit den kindern hilfe
gegeben werden kann wenn sie in not und
krisensituationen sind wenn sie
beispielsweise gewalt erfahren und das
ist alles komplett weggebrochen
die politik hat da ihre pflichten
kindern gegenüber nicht ausreichend
wahrgenommen
auch wenn die schulen zumindest
teilweise wieder öffnen damit sind
längst nicht alle probleme gelöst viele
shutter und regeln bleiben
warum werden die interessen der kinder
und jugendlichen nicht besser vertreten
das wollen wir die familien und
jugendministerin franziska giffey fragen
wir stellen fest im chor ohne kabinett
der kanzlerin hat sie keinen dauerhaften
platz im gegensatz zu sechs anderen
kabinetts kolleginnen und kollegen zum
beispiel aus den ressorts finanzen
verteidigung auswärtiges amt
mitbestimmung von kindern und
jugendlichen in der korona politik der
bundesregierung
fehlanzeige eigentlich hätte laut un
kinderrechtskonvention die kinder und
jugendlichen jahren allen schritten
befragt werden und angehört werden
müssen
warum ist das nicht passiert also
erstmal kann man das so eine meinung
nicht sagen dass irgendwas nicht
passiert ist sondern wir haben eine
jugend strategie der bundesregierung die
es schon im jahr 2019 verabschiedet
worden und da gibt es ein ganz großes
maßnahmenpaket was in allen ressorts
also es geht ja nicht nur darum dass
kinder und jugendpolitik im kinder
ministerium gemacht wird sondern es geht
darum dass es in allen politikbereichen
passiert und alle politikbereiche alle
ressorts der bundesregierung haben sich
darauf verpflichtet die jugend stärker
an den dingen die sie betreffen zu
beteiligen bei gesetzgebungsverfahren
das einen jugendtag gemacht wird jetzt
waren wir während unserer recherche in
familien und auch einrichtungen die sehr
unter druck geraten sind wo es wirklich
auch die frage gab müsste man nicht zum
schutz der kinder einfach andere regeln
als für erwachsene erlauben
also ich will noch mal ganz klar sein
wir müssen ein bisschen sortieren
in neun bundesländern war es ja so dass
die kitas nicht geschlossen worden sind
sondern dass an die eltern appelliert
wurden ist die kinder möglichst zu hause
zu halten also es gibt auch da eine sehr
unterschiedliche umsetzung in den
bundesländern sollte eine schule oder
kita geschlossen seien nur im notbetrieb
sein und die eltern haben eine wegen
keine arbeit aber es sind sechs kinder
zu hause auf 70 quadratmetern solche
fälle gibt es keine
diese kinder einen anspruch auf
notbetreuung sowohl in china als auch in
schule realität ist das leben der kinder
ist weiterhin eingeschränkt bis auf kita
und schule fast alle anlaufstellen für
kinder sind weiter zu eine der wenigen
ausnahmen die arche in berlin bernd
siggelkow und sein team machen einfach
weiter
zum wohl der kinder hier dürfen sie in
kleingruppen hausaufgaben machen
bekommen ein warmes essen und alles was
zu hause im shutdown fehlt also hier bei
uns in der ankündigung dass ich wegen
sie können toben sie können basteln und
malen und das sind alles sachen die zu
hause nicht passieren
es kommen meist kinder die es zu hause
nicht einfach haben
seit corona gibt es 150 neue anmeldungen
sie kommen in kleingruppen und um die
strengen infektions auflagen einzuhalten
werden die älteren mehrmals pro woche
digital betreut
zum beispiel mit experimentier stunden
vielleicht bewegen wir uns manchmal an
der grenze zur legalität aber in letzter
instanz ist es doch so wenn ich weiß
dass ich einem kind das leben retten
kann
nicht um zu sagen nein weil ich mich
selber schützen muss natürlich muss der
infektionsschutz genauso gewährleistet
werden ich darf kein kind einstecken und
das kind mich aber auf der anderen seite
muss sich für sein überleben sichern und
dann ist mir der kinderschutz wichtiger
[Musik]
damit passiert in der arche auf
pragmatische weise das was für die ganze
gesellschaft wären corona möglich
gewesen wäre
für kinder andere regeln schaffen als
für erwachsene
und sie gerade dadurch schützen dazu
ihre sorgen und wünsche ernst nehmen
ich wünsche mir dass das leben dann noch
mal so normal wird und zum training
gehen kann und ganz normal zur schule
[Musik]